con emoción en hollywood por el fatal
accidente actores directores escritores
amigos compañeros lloran la muerte de la
directora de fotografía de 42 años alina
hudgins las palabras solas no pueden
captar la pérdida de alguien tan querido
por la comunidad a efe y en a efe y nos
comprometemos a que halle na' hudgins
siga viviendo en el espíritu de todos
noticias absolutamente horribles y
devastadoras sobre la cinematografía
leena singh mi corazón está con su
familia no es el primer accidente mortal
de la industria lo recordó entre otros
mensajes la cuenta honorífica de twitter
del hijo de bruce lee brandon league
quien también murió en un contexto
parecido nuestros corazones están con
toda la familia deja lina hatching y
todos los involucrados en el incidente
en rust nadie debería morir por una
pistola en un rodaje nunca punto
tras algunas tragedias aumentaron las
normativas de seguridad del sector ahora
las autoridades investigan las
circunstancias en las que una pistola de
película causó una muerte real los
hechos ocurrieron este jueves en nuevo
mexico en el rodaje del western hasta
cuando el actor alec baldwin descargó el
arma de utilería sobre la directora de
fotografía que murió en el hospital el
director del film joel souza también
resultó herido en el episodio mientras
que según testigos baldwin salió
devastado tras declarar en la oficina
del sheriff